sozial Tourismus genau das wirft
CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz Millionen von
Ukrainern vor den Ukrainern also die vor
dem Krieg ins Ausland ziehen viele davon
ja auch hier zu uns nach Deutschland
Wohnung Geld Unterstützung vieles davon
gibt es hier tatsächlich schnell und
vergleichsweise unbürokratisch eventuell
zu unbürokratisch es gibt wohl immer
mehr Hinweise dass genau dieses System
also finanziell schnell zu helfen
ausgenutzt wird
wir erleben mittlerweile einen
sozialtourismus dieser Flüchtlinge nach
Deutschland zurück in die Ukraine nach
Deutschland zurück in die Ukraine mehr
als 1,1 Millionen Flüchtlinge insgesamt
bisher den Stand heute eine größere Zahl
sich dieses System zu Nutze machen da
haben wir ein Problem das wird größer
wir haben im Frühjahr darauf hingewiesen
dass dieses Problem entstehen konnte die
Bundesregierung hat sich taub gestellt
und jetzt macht Friedrich Merz die Rolle
rückwärts er schreibt da war bei Twitter
jetzt das zu meinen Äußerungen von
gestern über die Flüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine gibt es viel Kritik ich bedauere
die Verwendung des Wortes
sozialtourismus das war eine
unzutreffende Beschreibung eines in
Einzelfällen zu beobachtenden Problems
und weiter schreibt er mein Hinweis galt
ausschließlich der mangelnden
Registrierung der Flüchtlinge mir lag
und liegt es fern die Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine die mit einem harten
Schicksal konfrontiert sind zu
kritisieren wenn meine Wortwahl als
verletzend empfunden wird dann bitte ich
dafür in aller Form um Entschuldigung
das sagt Friedrich Merz jetzt zu seinen
Äußerungen
[Musik]